>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> I am pleased to turn the
stage over to Brendan Kiely.
[ Applause ]
>> Brendan Kiely: How are you doing?
Nice one -- I love the tone
of the [phonetic] response.
This is good.
So I am very, very grateful.
Thank you for that
super kind introduction.
And I am just really grateful to be
here at the National Book Festival
with all of you, and very
excited to share with you -
you can probably barely
see it out there,
but I know there is
a camera back there.
So I am just going to mug for the
camera and - I'm excited to share
with you "The Last True Love Story."
And I have been very fortunate.
I worked in a high school in
New York City for ten years.
And when I published
"The Gospel of Winter"
that was my final year of teaching.
And it was a remarkable experience
to be still teaching my classes
and speaking to students
about my own book.
And I just - I love this
confluence in the young adult world
because I think that young
adult readers are avid,
you know, and passionate readers.
And I feel so grateful to be a
writer in the community with them.
And I think YA readers
-- as you mentioned --
actually span all ages,
and so it's very cool.
So before I tell you
about this book,
let me tell you a family story.
In September of 2001,
actually, a number of folks
in my large Irish Catholic family
decided that it would be a good idea
to try to help my grandfather get
back to Ireland to the village
that his whole family
is from in order for him
to see it one last time, because
he had Alzheimer's disease.
And it was a thing that we wanted
to do to try to help him sort
of see this important
space one last time.
It was kind of a romantic idea.
And I don't know, in
hindsight, how smart it was.
In fact, it was a little dangerous.
And lo and behold,
I - so I got lucky.
I was one of the family members
who was chosen to go with him.
And I went with my grandmother and
my grandfather and my Uncle Bob.
And I met them over there.
And we all - we're touring
around, looking at the village.
And it was pretty remarkable
because I have a photo to this day
of my grandfather standing on a
stone bridge right in Stradbally.
And he had - he is holding
a postcard that he had;
and that was his only way of
remembering where in the village,
you know, his family was from.
Now the problem --
like I said, though --
is that it was a little dangerous.
He had Alzheimer's,
and there were moments
where he would really lose touch
with what we were doing
and where we were.
And it was quite frightening.
And it was frightening for me.
I was - I had recently
moved to New York.
I had recently graduated
from college.
And to see my grandfather
in this state where he was -
at one point we were at a
hospital because they had records,
and he thought he was
back in high school.
And it was disorienting to be there
and see this and to see the pain,
you know, that my uncle was
experiencing, and my grandmother,
and mostly for him because he would
go in and out of these moments.
And so I also knew I had to
do something else about this.
I really wanted to try to record his
stories and try to get them down so
that we had the family
recording of these stories.
And so at night, after we had
ventured to various places,
I'd sit down in the hotel room
with him and I'd say, "Grandpa,
tell me about life back in
Worcester, Massachusetts."
We're from Massachusetts.
"Tell me about growing
up in Worcester."
And he'd tell me all these
stories that were about, you know,
trying to get to school and
going through the neighborhood.
But his stories would wander.
And he - as he would - as often
happens, the stories began
to meander and go somewhere else.
And the anchor -- every
time, when he was coming back
and he realized he had gone
off or if he just didn't know
where he was anymore -- his anchor,
the refrain that he would
say every single time,
was "And this is why I
love your grandmother.
And this is why I love
your grandmother.
your grandmother."
And so for me, I wanted to write
a love story that was in homage
to the man who -- despite this
disease -- wanted to make clear,
in whatever moments of
clarity that he hung onto,
that the most important thing
that he could say was "I love you"
and "I love you" to my grandmother.
That matters to me.
Love is the foundation, I think,
for all three of the books
that I have been fortunate
enough to publish.
And I wanted to honor
that spirit in this book.
So what's this book?
This book is not - it does
not take place in Ireland.
It takes place in the United States.
And it is about, in
brief, Teddy Hendricks --
who is a 17-year-old boy -- a
lonely poet living in Los Angeles
who was basically raised
by his grandfather,
who is now in an assisted-living
facility in L.A.
because he has Alzheimer's disease;
and it's difficult take
care of him at home.
Teddy has been going to visit
him and spend time with him.
And he says - he's
talking to the grandfather.
And at the beginning of the book
the grandfather is searching
for this photograph
of the grandmother.
And finally they are
able to find it.
But he says to Teddy,
"Make me a promise.
Please don't let me
forget your grandmother."
She is deceased; she
died years earlier.
And the last thing he wants
is to experience that pain --
the pain of losing her
- the memory of her.
So he says, "Make me a promise.
Promise me you won't
let me forget her."
And it's an impossible
promise, but Teddy makes it.
And so he is trying to
figure out "How am I going
to get Grandpa across the country?"
Because Grandpa is
from Ithaca, New York.
"And how am I going
to get him there?
Because if I can get him there -- if
I can get him back to that hillside
where he first kissed the woman of
his life - the woman who is the love
of his life -- maybe we
can do something to try
to hold on to these memories.
We can go back to the church
where you were married,
and maybe that will conjure
up some of the memories."
It's a quixotic, romantic hope,
but he still wants to do it.
The problem is he can't drive.
So as he is - one night, as
he is out on the boardwalk --
the Venice Beach boardwalk
in L.A. --
and he is listening to
the 17-year-old girl
that he has a huge crush on, who
is this rocker who is rocking it
out on the Venice Beach Boardwalk.
They slip off and have an
adventure that evening.
And Carina, the rock star, learns
that he wants to make this trip.
And she wants to get out of
L.A., to get out to New York City
to jump-start her music career.
And so she says, "Teddy,
here's the deal.
Pack your bags.
We're stealing your mother's
car and we are driving
across the country tonight.
Let's do it.
Let's go."
So it's this adventure story.
And the important thing to
know about this essentially is
that this road trip story
is two love stories.
It's a love story of Carina and
Teddy beginning to fall in love
with each other for the first
time, and it's the love story
of the grandfather capturing
these memories and trying
to remember the love of his life --
trying to make love,
in fact, last forever.
So it's these two love
stories bound together.
And what's interesting about this,
in my mind, is this notion of trying
to figure out how to go home.
And so they are going
to Ithaca, New York.
And so the entire book is
in homage to "The Odyssey."
Imagine Odysseus but with
Alzheimer's, or a young Telemachus
who is trying to help an
Alzheimer's-afflicted Odysseus get
back home to the Penelope of Ithaca.
Unfortunately, it's
a Penelope in memory.
And so the whole book is
this homage to "The Odyssey."
So it's these love stories;
it's an homage to "The Odyssey."
And then here is the kicker,
because this is true as well.
The story is also about Carina.
Carina is, again, a rocker.
She's - wants to get out there
and jump-start this music career.
And what's fascinating is that
she is this huge musical library.
She can play songs from
all different eras.
She loves a lot of
contemporary music.
But she was adopted, and
part of her relationship
with her adoptive parents is that
she plays the songs of the 60's
and 70's that they grew up on.
She calls them "the ex-hippies."
And she has built this
music catalog of songs.
So while they are driving --
because every road trip
needs a good playlist --
she is playing some of those songs.
And those songs are what jog
the grandfather's memory.
Because as many of you probably
know, music resides in the mind
in a very different way than
your everyday short-term-
and long-term memory.
Music is more fluid.
And in fact, to this day there is a
lot of research that is being done
about using music as therapy for
people who have Alzheimer's disease
to help them tap into their
old memories, to help them tap
into emotion in the
moment -- all of that.
So Carina's rock songs, in fact,
are the songs that help the
grandfather begin to tap
into some of these memories.
So it was - it's all this in one.
And I'm very excited about it
because it's so deeply personal
to me, because it comes from that
space of family storytelling.
The other thing that
I'll share about the book
that I think is also just
important is that this book is -
if you are talking about
"home" and building home,
I think that's also a
conversation to talk about identity.
And something that's really
important for me as a writer in all
of my books and - is
acknowledging the fact
that I am a straight white male.
I think a lot about
identity construction.
And I think a lot about,
in particular --
as I did with the second book
that I co-wrote with Jason,
"All American Boys"
-- I think quite a bit
about the construction of whiteness.
And I think it's an important
subject that often gets left
out when we talk about
identity, because it's -
it is this "whiteness" that is part
of the dilemma when we are talking
about racial tension
in the United States.
So part of Teddy's journey
while he is on the road
and while he is witnessing some of
the racism that Carina experiences
as a transracial transnational
adopted child is to think, you know,
"Why am I not experiencing
this kind of, you know,
verbal attack in the
way that she is?"
And for him to reflect on
that across the country.
So this road trip is
to go back home.
This road trip is to try to
think about who we are as people.
But also it's Teddy's
thinking a little bit about
"Why are we refusing to talk about
this part of our national identity?"
And for me, that's the discussion
of white privilege and the harm
that it causes across the country.
So all those things are wrapped
up into one great big adventure.
And I had a lot of fun writing this
book, creating my own playlist,
and trying to get inspired with
music that really inspires me.
So that's the book.
And I would be - I would
love to take some questions
if anybody has some
questions for me.
I know there are some
microphones here.
And otherwise, I'm happy to
share with you some more.
But I'd love to take questions
if you guys have some questions.
It's hard for me to see.
[ Silence ]
[ Inaudible Audience Comment ]
Yeah, nice one.
>> My daughter, she's 13.
She's downstairs right now.
But she is - she calls
herself a feminist.
And I know that the narrative
around feminism is also,
in addition to racism, something
that's - we just don't seem
to want to address or face.
>> Brendan Kiely: Yeah.
>> Your character is a female.
Does that enter into
the conversation at all?
>> Brendan Kiely: Yeah,
yeah, absolutely.
I appreciate that.
Thank you.
Yes, absolutely.
So I think that's really a
valuable question to think
about in terms of love, as well.
And in this book it's a
heterosexual love story.
And I think it's really important
for the construction of identity
to think a little bit about gender
and sexuality and, in particular,
Carina as a character who is a
very strong female character.
But not all feminism has
to look a certain way.
And I think that's really important.
Like, when I - part of my
experience teaching was getting
to know all these great
students and getting
to know the different
kinds of students.
You know, I would teach a whole
bunch of different young women
who would all consider
themselves feminists.
But, you know, you
can't categorize them.
They don't look all the same.
They don't - you know, they
don't - they argue for it
in different ways, right?
And I think Carina is somebody who
is strong but also really grappling
with this notion of,
like, "I'm going to be -
I'm going to take charge of my life.
And that's OK.
I am often told that I
can't, but it's OK for me
to take charge of my
life in this way."
So for me it's really
important to think about that.
But do you have a followup?
>> Well I was just going to comment
that she pointed out to me recently
in something she saw on the
Internet that a huge percentage
of people do not identify
as feminist.
>> Brendan Kiely: Yeah.
>> But that same people
identify - they say yes,
men and women should be equal.
So yeah. Part of that
conversation is just why does
that word engender so much pushback?
>> Brendan Kiely: Yeah.
I agree. It really
- it makes me sad.
[Chuckles].
Because I just can't understand why
something as simple as, you know,
respect and looking at somebody not
through a sexualized lens or not
through some kind of preconceived
assigned category, but just to look
at a person and to say "Hey,
we're all in this together."
I - it just - it drives me
crazy that "feminism" is a word
that seems like a bad word.
Yeah.
>> OK.
>> Brendan Kiely: Hi.
>> It just feels so
weird on the microphone.
Is the book mainly about the road
trip, or the experience in New York?
>> Brendan Kiely: Wow!
Nice question.
This is like the future
literary critic for Kirkus.
This is amazing.
Nice job. So the book
is mainly the road trip.
Because I think when speaking about
love, I think it's really important
to have a story that is about
the process of falling in love --
a story about the long,
twisting turning.
Sometimes things are working out;
sometimes things are
not working out.
Road trip -- journey -- story,
as opposed to what it
might look like at the end.
I think too often, in fact, we
are given images on TV shows
or in magazines that set up
an expectation that, like,
"This is what love
should look like."
And instead of teaching us the
process, the living in love,
the line that the grandpa says in
the book is - to Teddy and Carina is
"The point of living is
learning how to love."
And it's a valuable lesson to
know that love is in action,
that love is in process, that love
is a journey, love is an adventure.
And it's not a place.
It's not necessarily a destination.
So - genius question.
That's really cool.
I really appreciate it.
What's your name?
>> Fiona.
>> Brendan Kiely: Fiona?
Fiona, we will be looking for
your analysis in years to come.
That's so cool.
That's great.
Thank you.
>> You're welcome.
[ Chuckling ]
>> Brendan Kiely: Is
there another question?
[ Inaudible Audience Comment ]
>> Sure. I'll briefly read.
Yeah, no problem.
I was - it's funny, because - so I
was just out in L.A. So I wanted -
so I launched the book in New
York, launched the book in L.A.
In New York I engaged a couple
of 17-year-old actors to do some
of the scenes and present
it that way.
And in L.A. there was -
I wasn't behind a micro -
I wasn't behind a podium, so
there was a much more interactive
experience speak - introducing
the book to high schools in L.A.
So I appreciate the opportunity.
I'll read one page because I
don't want to go over my limit.
And I'll read one page just
to try to set the scene to see
if it entices you at all.
Another cool thing is - it's
hard for you to see out there,
but there is a map at the
beginning and it's wicked cool.
And it's - I'm very excited because
I think books with maps, you know,
lead you into the story; and we
were hoping to do that with this.
But here it is.
All right.
And I really wish that the young
man who played Teddy in NY were here
to read this because he
is a fantastic actor,
and I just - he is amazing.
I can't wait to see
what happens with him.
All right, here it
is -- the prologue.
"Here's the situation.
We are lost in the desert
somewhere west of Albuquerque,
and the car we've stolen
is nose first in the dirt
with a flat tire --
G-pa, Carina, and me.
Each day that passes,
my grandfather's grip
on reality slips further
and further away.
And if I don't keep a close
eye on him, he might wander
into the dust and disappear forever.
Carina has walked off
in the other direction,
so pissed she's not
even talking to me.
And I am not sure she
wants to go all the way
across the country anymore.
But I made her a promise
I'd get her there.
I made G-pa the same
promise, to get him to see
that church one last time
before that disease wipes it
out of his mind and all his
memories of G-ma are gone.
All I want to do is keep these
impossible promises I've made.
But Mom, Carina's parents,
G-pa's doctor, the police,
and the rest of the freaking known
world are all out there looking
for us now; and we still
have over 2000 miles to go
and only three days left to do it.
I feel like this is
all coming to the end,
except I can't because it can't be.
It can't be the end -- not for G-pa,
not for Carina, and not for me --
because it is out here on the
road in the middle of nowhere
that I have finally come to
understand what my grandfather means
when he says 'The point of living
is learning how to love.'" So --
[ Applause ]
Thanks. The book begins "in media
res" -- in the middle of things,
because that's how
"The Odyssey" begins.
And we flash back to the night
that they are about to leave
and how they make the decision;
springing the grandfather; Carina,
you know, basically sticking it to
the music producer who is, you know,
ignoring her; and then
busting out of town
and heading out - heading east.
And I think it's important that
the book moves from the West Coast
to the East Coast because
so many road stories are the
opposite direction.
And for me this felt like an
opportunity to move west to east
as if we were kind of going
back in time a little bit,
like the grandfather who is kind
of digging back in his memory.
Yeah.
>> Hello. Forgive for asking what's
probably a very basic question
as the mother of a 14-year-old.
>> Brendan Kiely: Yeah.
>> When I was 14, we didn't
have young adult fiction.
So why do you think this is a
genre that has caught on and --
in an age of Internet and stuff?
And why do you write in it?
>> Brendan Kiely: So I
appreciate that question very much.
I, too, didn't really
technically grow
up reading young adult literature.
And in truth, I think many
young adult writers would say
that I don't write for
teens; I write about teens.
But I would actually say
that I write for teens.
I want to write for
teens and for adults.
And I think it's essential
that we are creating stories
that feel exciting and contemporary,
in particular to help teens
see themselves in literature,
see their lives, see their
pain -- see their, you know,
their everyday life in literature
and to not think of literature
as that thing that is assigned
in class but rather something
that is living and breathing
and a part of our everyday life.
And when - I kind of grew up
in the Church of Literature.
My mother worked the night
shift at Mass General Hospital,
and Sunday mornings,
so that she could go
to sleep when she came home.
My father would take me out
in Harvard Square in Boston
and would walk me, and my little
hand in his, from bookstore
to bookstore to bookstore.
And I feel like books
were my church.
And I'll never forget it.
It was, you know, such
a powerful experience.
And I think young adult
literature --
especially contemporary realism --
is trying to capture that
spirit of, like, "Hey.
You are living literature.
You are living the adventure.
Here it is!
Come check it out and stay
excited about literature."
I try to do that with "Macbeth,"
but that's an uphill
battle [laughs], you know?
And I feel like I can do it,
but I would rather do this.
And frankly I would love it if more
classes would pair young adult books
with some of the books that we
teach in our English courses.
For me, I really think
that it would be so fun
to pair this with "The Odyssey."
I read "The Odyssey" in
9th grade in high school,
and I taught "The Odyssey" to
various grades when I was a teacher.
And it would be cool to
have that kind of pairing.
So that's what I think.
I don't know where I'm even looking
right now; I know you're out there.
But I - but I'm - you know, I
really appreciate that question
because I think it's important
to think about it as a living,
breathing part of our lives.
And that's what young adult
literature is about for me.
So I appreciate that.
>> Can I ask a completely
irrelevant followup?
>> Brendan Kiely: Yeah, yeah.
>> My husband is in mourning over
Famous Ray's going out of business.
Do you have a backup Greenwich
Village pizza suggestion?
>> Brendan Kiely: I'm sorry.
He's mourning what?
>> Famous Ray's closed
in Greenwich Village.
>> Brendan Kiely: Oh yeah.
Yeah.
>> And we - I used to actually order
them to Washington for his birthday.
So I don't know where to order them
from Greenwich Village anymore.
Do you have any suggestion?
>> Brendan Kiely: I - yes.
I would say McNally-Jackson Books.
You can order plenty from there.
And it's not quite the Village.
I know it's Soho.
But it's --
>> No -- pizza.
>> Brendan Kiely: Oh, pizza.
Sorry -- that's why I was confused.
Pizza, yeah, Two Boots!
Come on! Two Boots is great.
>> Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
>> Brendan Kiely: That's hilarious.
Yeah, yeah.
I gotcha. Yeah.
>> Hi. Thanks for doing this talk.
>> Brendan Kiely: Thank you.
>> You all [phonetic] wrote "All
American Boys" with another author,
which to me seems a little bit
uncommon for a fiction book.
Could you talk a little bit about
what it was like to collaborate
on that versus being
the only author?
>> Brendan Kiely: Sure.
I really appreciate your question.
And it's interesting, because
Jason and I have spent a lot
of time touring together
and speaking together
And I am very passionate about "All
American Boys" and I think it's a -
it's a book that was born, really,
in a moment of rage and love
that we had as we were
kind of pounding our fists,
asking ourselves "What
are we going to do?
What is our responsibility
as young adult authors
to help the young adults
of our country begin
to process the absolute
horror that we see
on the news week after
week after week?"
-- young people of color,
people of color in general
who are being brutalized
by the police officers.
And it's a disgrace;
it's disgusting.
And we felt it was necessary
to try to do something
and say something publicly
about this.
And for us, it was really important
that we could do this together
because Jason and I
were already friends.
And the book really emerges
out of our friendship.
It doesn't emerge out of an idea.
It emerges out of the fact that
Jason, who is a black man who grew
up in DC, and Brendan, who is a
white man who grew up in Boston,
forged this really deep,
meaningful friendship.
And for us, that - to share that
passion that we have for each other
on the page was really,
really important.
It was also incredibly important
for us to lay open and be honest
about our cultural experiences
that influence the two
narrators in the book.
So in short, the book is about
one - it's about two boys --
one black, one white -- who go
to the same high school,
live in the same town.
But as Martin Luther King said in
1968 at Grosse Pointe High School,
"You know, these are two
Americas living side by side."
And we wanted to be very,
very honest about that --
and so for Jason to write out of
his cultural experience and for me
to write out of mine and to
speak very openly and honestly
about white privilege and
-- as I mentioned earlier --
the harm that it causes
many folks in our country.
So we wanted to do it
together because it felt
like it was right way to do that.
And we had so much trust built
between us that when it came
to the writing process we just
let each other do what we did.
And we wrote the book side by side,
checking in with each other --
like we would if we were
walking through DC and, you know,
going into a bank and having
two different experiences.
Or if we are walking in Boston
and going into a restaurant
and literally, side by side,
still having two very
different experiences
because of the inherent
racism in our country.
So we had to just tackle
that together,
and it was the best way to do it.
And by the way, I'll forever,
forever, forever be grateful
that I got to work on
a project like that
with such an unbelievably
amazing human being.
So thank you for giving
me the chance to say that.
Hi.
>> Is there going to
be a movie for that?
>> Brendan Kiely: It - for
"The Last True Love Story"?
>> Yeah.
>> Brendan Kiely: Yeah.
Are you a producer?
[ Laughter ]
I mean that would be great [laughs].
>> Student director, but no.
[ Laughter ]
>> Brendan Kiely: I would love it.
I would love it if there were a
movie of "The Last True Love Story."
I have in my mind a kind of
cinematic experience because,
in brief, I also got
to write this book
by taking the exact road
trip that's in the novel.
A buddy of mine said,
"Hey, man, I'll drive.
You just write."
And so I was in the passenger's
seat writing as we, you know,
went by the bluffs in New
Mexico or as we went, you know,
down into the desert in Arizona.
And it felt that kind of cinematic
experience through the window.
So I would love it
if it would happen.
And I - then you could
watch it and then read it.
Yeah.
>> Usually I read books
before watching it, but --
>> Brendan Kiely: Even better!
Even better!
Nice one. OK.
I'll take one last question,
and then I think I'm done.
So I - I'll take this last question.
>> All right.
So your book "The Gospel of Winter"
was about a young boy dealing
with the crisis in
the Catholic Church.
>> Brendan Kiely: Yeah.
>> And so I was wondering,
from your own background
and your own growing
up, how did that writing
and that final book
work with your family,
with your own personal connections?
You know, how did that
work in that dynamic?
>> Brendan Kiely: I deeply,
deeply appreciate that you bring
up "The Gospel of Winter."
Thank you so much.
It is a very important book in
my relationship with my family --
which I'll answer very quickly.
But I will say this: Whether
it's "The Gospel of Winter"
or "All American Boys" or
"The Last True Love Story,"
I think the fundamentals
that are key
to me whenever I approach a book is,
how do I help portray
the act of listening?
How do I portray this
discussion about love?
And those are those two - those
are the two things that are key,
I think, to the third pillar --
which is, how do we get a person
to stand up when things are
going wrong in society, right?
I want to help people, and
young people in particular,
feel like they have a roadmap
to learn how to listen,
to get to the road to empathy,
and that they know what
love is in its many forms.
And then they can stand up
and do something about it.
And so for me, writing
"The Gospel of Winter" --
which is a story about a 16-year-old
boy who is trying to decide whether
or not he will let the world know
he has been abused by his priest --
was a very powerful experience
for me to write about,
coming from an Irish
Catholic background in Boston,
going to Catholic school my whole
life, having a huge Catholic family.
And I was extremely nervous when
in - when writing the story.
In - as I tried my best, though,
it's not a book about
blaming people.
And I don't think any of my
books are about blaming people,
but instead helping us think
about being honest and letting
that become a part
of our road to love.
I will end with this, because the
person that made me the most nervous
to read the book was my
grandmother, who is the matriarch
of the family -- also the
woman who I was with in Ireland
when I was touring Ireland,
you know, with my grandfather,
and to whom this book is
dedicated along with my wife.
Because she said to me, when
she read the book, "Brendan,
your book 'The Gospel
of Winter' reminds me
of Solomon asking God
for a listening heart."
And for me, I still have
goose bumps just repeating
that because that's
my goal, you know --
to help us think about how
to have a listening heart.
And that's my goal in all my books.
So I appreciate that.
Thank you Grandma [laughs].
[ Applause ]
So I believe I'm done.
If you would like to join me in
the signing line, I think it's -
it's 5 o'clock, and I think it's
Lane 20 in Section A. Come on down.
Love to chat more.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.